this is a production of Cornell
University
pleasure to be here at Cornell for many
reasons
there's a movie called Ghostbusters in
which they are trying to
you know make a character as nerdy as
possible and this character says I love
mold spores and fungus and so do I so I
like to start my talks with that so you
you know where I'm coming from
um here's the plan
I'm going to spend a lot of time in
introduction and then go on and talk to
you about some of my fairly recent
research and then wrap up with some
generalizations
so it'll be a Shaggy Dog introduction
I spent most of my career at Tulane
University which has the advantage of
being in New Orleans Louisiana it has
what's called the geographic endowment a
lot of people go to Tulane because they
want to live in New Orleans
um it's it's a wonderful City it's often
described as the most European of
American cities but that's not true it's
it's more an afro-caribbean City a lot
of voodoo and and and it's a very black
City It's a Wonderful City special
environment and
it's you know the birthplace of jazz
fabulous food anyone who's been there
knows how hard it is to keep from
gaining weight actually the coffee house
culture goes way back before Starbucks
and uh is uh still going strong and if
you've ever been to New Orleans you know
about the wonderful Beignets Carnival
and all these things come together here
I'm a girl who grew up in Brooklyn New
York and I fell in love with New Orleans
and I think of all the things I love
about New Orleans most is there's
something about the people and the
attitude and the and the way people
interact the city you can't live there
without picking up some of it now having
said this while I was in New Orleans I
did research on one of these nerdy
fungal topics
I studied mycotoxins especially
aflatoxin which is usually introduced as
a singular but it's a family of
compounds I've given you the structures
of the major ones and they're they're
made by several Genera of of aspergillus
a major fungal genus
um
in as much as I have a scientific claim
to fame it's that I isolated a lot of
block mutants in the Apple toxin pathway
and I was lucky many of these blocked
mutants turned out to be colored and we
with great difficulty over the course of
more than 20 years laboriously worked
out different steps in the pathway and
when gene cloning came along
we were able to discover that the steps
were linked and
um this became a paradigm for other
mycotoxins and for other secondary
metabolites that these unusual small
molecules tend to be biosynthesized by
these clustered Gene Pathways and those
of us who work on Apple toxin are really
proud that we beat the penicillin people
just think of all that industrial money
for all those years and we happened to
get there first
um certainly I did not do the work alone
I isolated a lot of the mutants much of
the gene cloning was done by parent Quan
Chang and jujang Yu Nancy Keller who's a
graduate of Rutgers was deeply involved
at Cleveland was the director of the
group and there were other people
especially Deepak botnager and Gary
Payne's group I'm I'm the one I'm lucky
I got a lot of the credit but it was
definitely a group effort as science
always is
now if you know anything about fungal
toxins and I expect many of you here do
they're a big problems in the global
food chain without a doubt fungal toxins
are bad they infect our our human diets
they infect our animal diets and they
cause a variety of terrible diseases
when when ingested and depending on the
toxin different problems
more controversially
mycotoxins have been blamed for certain
building related habitats when people
live in moldy buildings and this is a
sort of famous picture in the world of
indoor air I mean that's a really
multi-building but when people live in
mold
contaminated habitats it's been
hypothesized that they are involved in
something that's generically called sick
building syndrome not a good name a
bunch of these non-specific symptoms you
know there are lots of things that can
give you a sore throater that can make
you fatigued or have a headache or cause
insomnia and there's this idea that when
they all happen together and you're
living in a mold contaminated house
they're caused by
um exposure to fungi and perhaps to
these these toxins
um my perspective
um has been for a long time that
although mycotoxins really are a problem
when they come through the diet it's
hard to be exposed to enough of them
through the respiratory system and
enough of any one toxin to cause this
variety of
problems that I don't think they are the
cause mycotoxins are the cause of sick
building syndrome fungi might be there
might be allergic reactions and I
actually
sent to college one of my sons to an
expensive private college by
taking consulting jobs for insurance
companies where I would say hey this
person is sick and yes mycotoxins are
terrible but I don't think they're sick
for that reason and I don't like
Consulting but he graduated from the
University of Chicago without a
scholarship and without any debt because
I I work for the insurance
okay so I'm saying all this to tell you
I knew a lot about sick building
syndrome and I've told you I lived in
New Orleans and many of you are too
young to remember this but there are
many of you who I think do a really bad
hurricane hit New Orleans in 2005. and
here's a picture
that was published on the internet and I
saved the newspaper when I went back
this newspaper was uh that says Katrina
takes aim was was lying on the breakfast
room table in my in my uh breakfast room
and I'm sorry I didn't take a picture of
the the paper with the chaos around it
but I did save the paper so let me tell
you a little bit about the Topography of
New Orleans
New Orleans is between the Mississippi
River which is in this image circling
around as a ribbon going up and down and
then below a very very large Inland Lake
that most people haven't heard of after
the great lakes and the Great Salt Lake
it's the biggest lake in the country
Lake Pontchartrain
and much of New Orleans is below sea
level so this topographic map shows the
areas in blue that are below sea level
that when the various levees broke from
the lake filled into the city the
Mississippi River behaved itself it was
Lake Pontchartrain that that uh that
spilled and this engineering diagram
tells you what happened the city
basically filled to sea level and
everybody found out where they were in
relationship to sea level
this is how it looked from the sky you
can see the Mississippi River there 80
percent of the city flooded that's four
out of five people
um neighborhoods you can see the trees
here the the parts of the city nearest
the river didn't flood but most of the
city did
um and uh anyone who knows about mold
knows when there's that much water
fungus is going to grow
and I here's a cartoon that came out not
that long after Hurricane Katrina when
the water subside the problem is going
to be mold and it was
there's one image that I found on the
internet of
of post Katrina New Orleans jujang you
one of the people who was involved in
the Apple toxin work with one of my few
colleagues who took a picture of his
home look at that look at the piano
he had flooding all the way up to the
ceiling
um
our home it also flooded we'd evacuated
before the storm the National Guard
wouldn't let us go home so we actually
we didn't get back for five weeks and my
husband's from New Jersey we evacuated
to Jersey I called a buddy at uh Rutgers
University said can I make some media
I'm going to fly home and I'm going to
sample my house and so
I did and here's the entryway
antique clock you can see the different
places on the wall as as the Army Corps
of Engineers was pumping out the city
here's the living room
there was no longer any standing water
but you can see where Furniture had been
knocked over
here's our family room I had made these
pitiful attempts I'd put a lamp up on on
a table thinking this room might get a
little bit of water because it was the
lowest in the house I mean it was bad it
was mold everywhere
here's an ornamental cityomycy which has
is just these when I cultivated that
black stuff that was all pure
aspergillus Niger and I went into this
hoping to find a new species of
aspergillus or a new mycotoxin or
something and and so I sampled away what
the pictures can't tell you is the way
it smelled
uh I was a good girl I was wearing an
n95 mask I was wearing gloves I had long
sleeves on because I knew I was in a
moldy house and as I took the pictures I
kept feeling sick smelled nauseating and
I go outside and I rest for a while and
I'd sample some more
and I became a convert I said you know
there might be something to the sick
building syndrome something is really
wrong with being in this house and I'm
wearing a mask and I know a lot about
mycotoxins and I know a lot about spores
and I said you know they put out gases
too volatile organic compounds and so
exposure to the molds in my house is
what gave me this what I call conversion
experience
well meanwhile
Rutgers where I'd been making the media
and brought the fungi offered me a job
and so the day after I got tenure at
Rutgers I called my Dean at Tulane and
resigned my tenure Tulane and I moved
late in life I mean I could have retired
and um I spent a lot of my early years
working on the office for women in
science which was which was gratifying
but I also started this work on the
volatile organic compounds so that's the
Shaggy Dog introduction now I'm going to
give you a mini lesson on volatile
organic compound
definition
low molecular mass they're little
molecules look at those little molecules
and they easily vaporize and any of us
who are scientists know about Benzene
ethanol you leave ethanol out with when
it's not covered it evaporates toluene
our solvents tend to be then then
anesthetic gases we've all heard of
ether we've all heard of chloroform
um many of the synthetic chemical
compounds are known to be air pollutants
and the Environmental Protection Agency
and American Cancer Society have have uh
good science that tells you about these
synthetic volatiles less is known though
about the biological volatiles and I
didn't know this when I started but
everything we smell is in the volatile
phase if you can smell it it's a
volatile that's how our olfactory system
works and hey you know the biggest group
of human genes
are Factory sensing genes I'd never
known that and they not only come
through a respiratory system but they
can be absorbed through the skin and
this is one of my buddies at Rutgers
Charlie weschler he is very interested
in volatile compounds and he did this
experiment in Denmark with some buddies
where they went in wearing shorts and
they breathe clean air and they had a
volatile brought into the room and then
they measured all their pee and poo for
a couple of days and they founded this
particular compound I'm forgetting which
one it was that 50 of what they were
absorbing was coming in through the skin
that it's a so when we think of
volatiles I don't think we necessarily
think that our bodies are absorbing
compounds but it's not just inhalation
we can get them from a various variety
when you read the research it's kind of
fun I've read some book on perfume some
of the very best research has been done
by perfumers and they keep looking for
this human pheromone that'll make us
sexually attractive to whoever it is
we're trying to I don't know if they
succeeded but if you've ever bought an
expensive perfume you know they make a
lot of money
um
we we know smells um smells are actually
hard to put a name on but often we can
recognize things like vanilla or Ginger
or or
lemon here are some of the fungal
volatiles that we all tend to recognize
geosmin which is also made by bacterias
that earthy smell very low quantities
give that order the one I've been
working mostly on mushroom alcohol a
limonene is also made by some some fungi
and they tend to have very low odor
thresholds teeny tiny amounts we think
there's a lot there and um
and if this makes them incredibly hard
to study you think there's a lot there
and there's very little
um
and when you start studying them you
discover what fungal volatiles you get
have a lot to do with what the fungus is
growing on because many of them are just
break down products so of the substrate
and so the term volatom or volatatome
much of what's observed there is not
necessarily a metabolic product of the
fungus it's a metabolic breakdown
product of the fungals enzyme that's
breaking down something else that said
there are some famous fungal odors stink
horns if you've ever gone collecting
mushrooms you may know just how really
bad they smell they smell terribly bad
and then there's perhaps the the natural
product that is thought to be most
likely to be a real aphrodisiac Truffles
and they have a very special odor
interestingly people who've been
studying have discovered it has to do
with the bacteria that live in the
Truffle not really the trouble but
that's another story the people who've
done the best work in signaling are
chemical ecologists where they're often
called info chemicals or semiochemicals
and there's some really really good
insect work on volatile
and uh
provide perspective remember I told you
I'd known a lot about sick building
syndrome just gonna close that up there
what are we doing just closing that up
there so that they can see your slides
okay sorry
um
people in Scandinavia had said that okay
we have the stick building syndrome
maybe it's not the mycotoxins maybe the
it's the volatile that I had known about
that so now I'm going to get to talking
about my work long time introduction so
I hypothesize hey these Scandinavian
guys maybe they're right the bad smell
in my home might contribute to sick
building syndrome and as we have started
doing this research we have focused on
on a couple of eight carbon volatiles
and uh We've we've used two approaches
we've exposed genetic model organisms to
Growing mold and then we've used
chemical standards of individual vocs
and we came to doing this after years of
studying the moles I'd isolated and we
found nothing new nothing new no new
species no new volatile but when we
don't think anybody else has done this
using the genetic models and that's
where we hit the Pay Dirt
so the one I have studied most mushroom
alcohol simple eight carbon alcohol like
many volatile that has enantiomers and
they have slightly different smells to
me they both smell moldy theoretically
the S1 smells more like the moldy cheese
and the R1 more like the mushroom smell
but that's what it says in the
literature I can't really tell the
difference and we wasted a lot of time
trying to find different activities for
for the two enantiomers and basically
they're both active the r which is the
natural one is is more active but
they're both active
and it's found in human sweat
it happens to be the compound that
attracts malaria mosquitoes it's also
known to deter a lot of compounds and
the first time I Googled the terms one
option three all Plus insect down came
like a thousand citations there aren't
there aren't that many in them the
mycological literature but let me tell
you the entomologists believe what I say
not that my colleges don't always and
it's as I say this compounds have been
used to attract uh
malaria mosquitoes
there are close relatives that have been
isolated as for in germination
Inhibitors and have been active in C
elegans tests
um
they have been studied for effects on
humans and actually there's a a eight
carbon volatile that's used to inhibit
essential tremors in in humans and so
there's a big literature around these
eight carbon volatiles but for my
colleges haven't spent much time
studying it except as flavor
so my my lab set out to say okay what
were the fungi I found what volatiles
did they make can they be tested in
genetic models we've done pretty well on
one two three we haven't done so well on
finding out whether they cause sick
building syndrome
and that's that turns out to be a big
problem what did I find in my home
mostly trichoderma
this is because trichoderm is the soil
fungus and my house had been flooded
with Muddy soil
as I said we didn't find any new
compounds we spent a lot of time
isolating volatiles it's not easy to do
we found that our molds made lots of
different cocktails but it was several
years of not much new and it's when we
started using the genetic models that we
hit the Pay Dirt and here I give a lot
of credit to RT nmdar who was a postdoc
who led the product project on the
drosophila Fly
so sometimes in our studies we expose
larvae
sometimes we expose adult flies when you
expose the larvae you can watch them
through an occlosion test and see how
many pupate and how many turn into
adults and how many have morphological
abnormalities around with the adults you
can see how they behave and you can also
see whether they live or die and you can
Count Their dead bodies we tried to do
that with c elegans and they would just
run away and it was very unsatisfying
because you couldn't find dead bodies
with persopoly you can see the dead
bodies and so here's some of the molds
from Hurricane Katrina and here are just
some uh studies that are over 10 years
old now where we were able to kill a lot
of drosophila flies by just growing them
next to trichoderma volatiles and then
we started studying these chemical
standards and the orange line is the
mushroom alcohol that compound that
attracts malaria mosquitoes and in a
week we could kill our flies by exposing
them to fairly low quantities of this
now RT had worked on
paraquat which is a an herbicide in
Parkinson's disease for her PhD
dissertation and she said wow these
flies are behaving the way they do when
exposed to paraquat there's this blind
model for Parkinson's Disease and so she
started watching the way the Flies moved
and sure enough the one often three all
was hacking the way paraquat does in
causing these parkinsonian symptoms in a
fly model and one of the great things
about drosophila I've taught genetics
for many years but I'd never had flies
in the lab is
it is a hugely well-studied genetic
organism so you can write to the
Bloomington stock Center and say hey
send me a strain that has green
fluorescent protein in front of my
favorite Gene and they just send it to
you 27 or something like that so we
bought these flies that had gfp and from
in front of the dopenergic neurons and
exposed the the one octane Trio and you
can see here's the down regulation of
the of the genes and then
we got some flies that were transgenic
that had some special things in the in
the um fly genome that were over
expressing and we were able to get rid
of our effect and I don't want to go
into too much detail there but we
definitely were able to show that you
can cause Parkinson's disease in a
drosophila fly and had some very nice
molecular data that shows that it was
related to some of the the genes
involved in dopamine transport and that
one can think that possibly
um similar things are happening in
mammals I've written three NIH grants
where I try to get funding to move this
into Miser rats and I get back with you
she is not a neurobiologist okay and I
have so I've moved on to other things
but one good thing that's come out of it
is I have a bioassay and um if people
want to have some idea about the
toxicology of of fungi you can use the
fly model and so we had our own
hurricane in New Jersey not that many
years after Katrina and uh it was a
different kind of hurricane it came late
in the year it was salty water not like
Pontchartrain it was cold blah blah blah
but I got invited to go out collecting
molds after Hurricane Sandy and
um yeah I tell you about the work with
women in science even though a lot of
women graduate students look at who gets
invited to go out collecting molds after
Hurricane Katrina and and I was a senior
scientist and they sort of needed me so
I got to go out with the guys more than
once we brought a bunch of fungi back we
measured the percent mortality some
fungal volatiles didn't kill the Flies
others killed them a lot we grew up the
mold and tested
um the volatile they're making and one
of the problems with this is it's very
much a
snapshot you you measure the volatiles
and that's what you're getting at that
instant with that fungus grown at that
time and I guarantee you if you do 10
readings at different times you'll get
different things but
here's one of the fungi that was killing
a lot of the fungus and you can see that
at uh seven days over half of the
volatile it was making was one octane
Frio and here's one of the non-toxic
fungal volatiles that's not making
anyone Octonauts free all at all
you can use this as a as a Toxicology
test so anyway flies went well and um we
I I'm going to be talking too long as it
is but we've been using these flies to
study some medically important fungi
aspergillus fumigatis and done some very
very nice work with a recent graduate
showing that aspergillus fumigatous
volatiles are toxic and that we think
some of them are acting as as
pathogenicity factors
I'm in a botany department and I had
students who said well we don't want to
work with flies so we're going to use
another genetic model and here's work
done by Richard hung who was an
undergraduate of mine at Tulane and
Samantha Lee who's a a Rutgers graduate
all the way through and the plant work
is harder because plants need sunlight
and you have to use enclosed spaces and
we spent a lot of time developing
different models and you can see here
this group one where we'd have a whole
bunch of peachy plates on the bottom
with the fungi growing and the plants
above and you always have to keep the
fungus far apart from the target
organism so that they're they're not
touching and that's the great thing
about volatile stuff no touching it's
all through the atmosphere and we found
that one octane Trio can inhibit
germination and it can kill
vegetative growth and
and uh
Richard hung I remember when he first
sent me this picture I thought that he'd
made a mistake because everything we had
done to this point the volatiles were
doing bad stuff and he sends me this
picture and I say are you sure you have
that right do you have the labels mixed
up and he said no I have it right turns
out that fungi can make eridopsis grow
better
and uh it's uh
a series of uh bio control strains that
have been used and known to do lots of
things turns out that many of them make
plants grow better when you're not
touching the trichoderma to the volatile
and it took a long time Samantha worked
this out to figure out that we could put
a little peachy plate with the
trichoderma and have some plants on the
other half otherwise the trichoderma
would just grow over and eat the plant
and it took about two years for the
simple system to be developed once you
did we tested lots and lots of
trichoderma strain actually most of them
made volatiles that made plants grow
better a couple of them not so good and
I'm going to rush through this and so
she's got this whole wonderful
collection of trichodermas from a guy
named Carrie Samuels and we grew them
with the plants and we measured the
amount of chlorophyll and most of them
were improving it some of them didn't do
much and then grew all the strength and
ran GC Mass back in houses and you know
lots and lots of work and then look to
see which volatiles were being made by
the different trichoderma strains and
here are the individual compounds that
were tested and then Samantha tested
each one of these compounds individually
to see whether they made aridopsis grow
better or not and whether there was more
chlorophyll in the aerodopsis and
um found that uh some of them improved
plant growth some of them didn't do much
and then we chose we only had enough
money for one transcriptomic study so we
studied the volatile that it had the
single best Improvement under the
conditions we used and it was deathing
and we tested it at physiological
compound whatever and we did a
transcriptome study and we found that
there are only a few genes that were
upregulated and we'd really expected The
Oxen genes to be upregulated and that's
not what we found at all we found that
the major thing that desine was doing
was down regulating a lot of genes and
it was down regulating a lot of stress
genes which is which is interesting so
this plants you know doesn't know that
things are bad because it's stress genes
are down regulated and it's growing
better and I had a visiting scientist
from Iran who had been studying a strain
over there and showing that volatiles
were improving tolerance to Salt stress
and so we we hypothesize that what's
happening the reason these plants can
grow better in the presence of
trichoderma is that the volatiles are
turning off their stress genes and they
don't know they have salt around it may
not be good for them in the long run but
they grow better so trichoderma makes
lots of vocs the volatiles change
depending on the time but if you study
them one by one you can can break down
and and show something of their of their
um
behavior and at least with this one
volatile it down regulates stress genes
one more model yeast
yeast has the opportunity of giving us a
window on what's Happening everything
I've been telling you is
phenomenological I put in a volatile I
get an effect wouldn't it be nice to
know what a volatile is doing and we've
made less progress here than some but
we're making progress so you know yeast
is even better than drosophila it's
better than aridopsis it's a fungus and
you can treat this particular fungus
like a bacterium so we've um
studied a whole bunch of different
volatiles in
against yeast and we have isolated some
uh
strains that behave differently and we
have we have tested the volatiles
against a yeast knockout Library
and
um you have to first find out what
concentration of a given volatile will
kill the yeast and then you run it
through the whole yeast knockout library
and see which strains are are still
behaving the same way and I didn't do
this work but we luckily in our building
have a facility that does the yeast
knockout library and yeast is an even
better model system maybe than
drosophila fly if you're if you're
looking for molecular events and we um
went ahead and tested different
um
compounds against the the library and
look to see which genes were there and
this this slide is perhaps the single
easiest
to describe in which we are looking at
the genes that were sensitive to
one Octon Trio and that it's kind of
backwards it means that when these genes
are absent the yeast is able to grow at
a concentration that normally is killing
it and so you have this kind of
backwards things that the resistance
genes are somehow involved in in
um
enabling the yeast to grow even though
it would normally be killed and up there
in the upper left or the main ones of
those
and um
they uh were screened to different types
and we found out that the single biggest
category was involved in endosomal
transport and this work
um
is is not yet published because uh
Shannon morath the PHD student who is
working on it sort of dropped out during
the pandemic and so I have the the work
is on hold and I'm I'm very upset she
hasn't come back and we have all this
beautiful data that hasn't been
published but the
um genes involved in the one option
three all resistance have to do with
some kind of sorting at the endosome and
um we we believe it has to do with
getting the compounds into the cell and
when those genes are messed up it
doesn't get into the cell and it doesn't
kill the fungus so
uh the first attempt that we know of to
determine the mechanisms of what's
happening with gas phase fungal
volatiles
and that there are a lot of different
genes that are turned on and off and I
didn't go into the details about
tryptophan biosynthesis and ergosterol
biosynthesis I did mention the Anderson
somal transport and it's sitting there
waiting to be written if Shannon morath
would come back from pandemic and she
hasn't it
okay let me wrap this up
um
volatile organic compounds they're
proving to be way more interesting and
way more powerful than I expected when I
started this I remember thinking gosh if
I could find one effect every time I
turn around I'm drowning in effects
every time I test a new volatile in any
model there are effects
and
I I started it because I was interested
in thick building syndrome or building
related illness I haven't made much
progress on that but let me tell you it
just opened up this whole world some of
it's personal
I didn't pay much attention to Smells
until I started this
yeah I smell food or smell flowers or
smell something bad it was all hedonic
it was good or bad I never gave any
thought to why is that good or bad why
what is it that I'm I'm sending you so
now it's it's improved my world it
really has in in many many many many
levels
um it's made me think differently about
all the years when I'd open an incubator
and I'd smell something and I just
ignored it that's the fun day growing
never paid any attention to why they're
making that smell sometimes culture
collections these fungi that are in the
deep freezer they smell really weird
they're under a lot of stress
um I've noticed that science is very
much done in the liquid phase the
experiments we do it's all fluid it is
and we just constantly throwing away the
headspace almost everywhere I know I
sometimes have trouble publishing papers
because people don't seem to understand
that's what's different about this paper
is it's all in the gas phase that we're
not doing this the way most scientists
do
so um hey I'm I'm acutely aware that I'm
in the Twilight of my career and so my
job is to try to inspire the younger
generation look in your whatever you're
studying just pay a little attention to
the things that smell around you and you
might be very surprised just just how
important those compounds are and how
frequently when people lose an effect
when they're trying to do an extract it
may have to do with the fact that
they've just ignored what's gone off in
the gas phase
it really is an underexplored Frontier
in science it's a very underexplored
Frontier in science and it's not just
for fungi it's for all kinds of things
and I I I now kind of believe in
aromatherapy unfortunately aromatherapy
books are a little too for me but but
there's probably something there maybe
lavender does do something best to make
us sleep better you know it hasn't been
studied well but there's almost
something there and then you know I'm
I'm more a microbiologist than a plant
biologist and there when you teach
microbiology a lot of the textbooks
start out about oh those people in the
old days they used to think that you got
terribly sick because of bad air and we
know that you get terribly sick because
of the malaria parasite for the anthrax
bacterium or whatever and aren't they
stupid but suppose some of the time some
of the time people were getting sick
because there was something so nasty in
the air I mean often all theories have
some kernel of wisdom and they say
chemical ecologists have done some of
the best work and there is a division in
biology between naturalists and
and molecular biologists that is often
hard to breach and the chemical
ecologist and the entomologists have a
lot to teach those of us who work on on
fungi
um you know we know that the stinkhorn
smells bad
um maybe these compounds are doing some
other things that we should know more
about
and when people go looking for new
medications I mean there are some
medications that we inhale
I I think they're probably some drugs to
be found out there that are little
molecules that could be you know drug
companies should be looking for it and
and you we've all seen how dogs behave
and the way they they greet each other
and uh I I think dogs can teach people a
few lessons I'm very very high on the
potential
having said that
I want to remind you right at the
beginning I mentioned that some of the
volatiles that most people have heard of
are volatile anesthetics
we've been using them for 150 years we
know what they do they work do we know
how they do it
and I've hung around some
anesthesiologists and there's some
recent work on some volatile gases doing
something to mitochondrial function and
killing the mitochondria but doesn't
necessarily tell us what it's doing to
our brains to make us not feel pain and
hey just think of all that medical money
and all those anesthesiologists and here
I am this Funko researcher with a kind
of big ego because remember I told you
we beat the penicillin people I say hey
maybe we fungal people can teach those
who were working
using the power of gases to learn
something about what they are doing
biologically
um I found this slide three forms of
anesthesia General local and what I'm
doing talking too long so I'm going to
wrap up my favorite quote
uh for for being able to say thank you
he said it in French Claude Bernard art
is I
science is way and it it's interesting
that you know we scientists have a
reputation for being these isolated
Geniuses we work together with people so
much more than artists or writers do
that it's it's a it's a misplaced
misplaced generalization and none of us
could get what we've done
done if we don't work with others and so
I want to say thank you to some of my
colleagues and there's Shannon morat
standing in the middle next to the guy
in the t-shirt and she's the one who's
sitting on all the beautiful yeast data
and has disappeared during the pandemic
Jason Richardson who is just in the
process of moving to the University of
Georgia who helped with the Parkinson's
work
um other members of the lab and I had
meant to put some arrows in here but in
the headscarf had deal now Maliki who's
done the beautiful work on aspergillus
fumigatus that I didn't tell you about
and Kayla pennerman who um is front in
the back who who has done a lot of our
bioinformatics study
and at the very end I I can't tell you
how much it means to me to be here at
Cornell
When I Was An undergraduate and you can
see how old I am by this date I want to
NSF summer Fellowship in the Agronomy
Department here at Cornell in the summer
of 1962 there am I 40 pounds ago and uh
standing with a man I can't remember his
last name his first name was Lacey and I
worked on a porridge crop called bird's
foot tree foil and the experiments
weren't much but it was the first time
I'd ever done research that was not in a
formal lab and so there was no answer
remember wow when I do this it better be
right because nobody knows what it's
going to be and that was very exciting
to me
and uh here's a picture of the Agronomy
Department it's a pretty male place in
fact they had to build a special
bathroom for for me and the other woman
who was out there in the field and I
reported to a guy named Robert ceney who
unfortunately I've written to him a
bunch of times and he never wrote back
but at the end of the summer he said to
me and I'm have it in quotes but these
are almost his words he says you have a
knack for this sort of thing you ought
to go to graduate school and become a
cytogeneticist like Barbara McClintock
I'd never considered graduate school I'm
a first generation American my parents
didn't have much formal education for me
to go to college was a big deal I'd
never heard of Barbara McClintock
I applied to graduate school and Cornell
was my first choice right after
Christmas I was rejected by Cornell and
I remember that it was a bad vomit in
life I had decided I was going to go to
cytogenetics following Barbara
McClintock however it wasn't all bad and
I was accepted everywhere else in the
University of Chicago gave me a very
nice fellowship and I've never regretted
going to the University of Chicago or
the career that started but you know I
wouldn't have applied if we weren't for
Cornell and I have a special I I still
love Cornell and you know I can't say
they did me a favor because I think I
would have had a good career if I'd come
here but I had a wonderful career out of
Chicago and uh no no regrets whatsoever
um
hey
wake up and smell the fungi
I'm delighted to be here and thank you
for listening
um thank you very much for an amazing
lecture we thought that we will first
give a chance to grad students to ask
some questions so are there any grad
student questions over here
okay I'm I'm gonna do a grad student
thing that's going to embarrass them I I
had meant to show a picture but one one
of the students didn't send me an
appropriate picture but I have three
former record students here and I'd like
them to stand up Marianne Andrea and
Jocelyn all our students from Rutgers
who were here at Cornell doing great
things and I'm delighted they're here
and so it's part of why I wanted to come
is to see my former students thrive in
the place that didn't let me in
um well if there are not grad student
questions maybe other questions here
before we go to Geneva
thanks for that hug so uh my question is
uh so we always think there is a trade
off between product community and fun
girls and you were showing the the wall
hell compound will promote bad girls do
you think those plans will be more
susceptible to pathogens they they might
be they might be and I I'm not a
botanist so I don't know much about
plant immunity
almost all the research I've seen has
been about
um the saline resistance and they
definitely are growing better and it's
interesting a lot of the work is coming
out of the Middle East like the student
was from Iran and there's some
researchers in Egypt working on this
um there hasn't been much molecular
biology or phenomenology it's just that
hey it's happening I don't I don't know
and so you're going to need somebody who
knows about plant immunity to answer
that question my sense is though these
plants may be doing some other things
right because trichoderma is known to be
such a wonderful organism to have in the
soil and I've focused on something that
most people don't pay attention to but
trichoderma does a whole bunch of things
so if it's there in the soil growing on
the roots
and touching the plant and improving
other aspects at the same time it's
turning down some of the stress genes
they may be compensating and if there's
anything I have learned about biology is
that it's always more complicated than
you think always
thank you so I have a question
um thinking about volatiles as a method
of communication
um how important do you think it is to
elucidate like what the purpose of the
communication is because you know you
have different like eavesdropping
between organisms or versus like you
know co-evolved sort of interaction
um how do we study that and then also
like
is it important to know whether or not
these Communicator the communicative
signals are like supposed to be received
by this organism or if it's just like a
not a good it depends I mean this is
there's so many signaling things that
happen so to to make a generalization
yeah I I wouldn't even know how to begin
when you isolate a given interaction
which we do and we're reductionists
you're often leaving out a whole lot and
I am not ever going to be a good systems
biologist I I because I'm trained in
genetics I tend to be very reductionist
but we need to do a better job of being
able to study hundreds of things at the
same time over time
and many organisms working together and
and so when I'm giving advice to those
younger and stronger I I say not only
study the volatiles but hey learned a
lot of bioinformatics while you're at it
um Laurie
um I was really interested about the um
that the cells are importing like it's
explicitly importing the volatiles as a
fencing mechanism or do you think that
it's food or some other reason that is
active like a do you think it's active
import
yeah I don't know whether it's an active
import or not it I I am only at the very
edge of this with this yeast work that
um
there is definitely something going on
at the membrane whether it's a passive
or an active thing do not know
it's it's certainly worth looking at
um that you know when I go back to the
anesthetic gases a lot of those are just
diffusing through
and so one of the interesting things
about small molecules like this is they
seem to be able to do it without as much
active transport but again
there's just this big lacuni we don't
know we simply don't know and there's so
many volatiles and so many things and
here just I've been very much focusing
on one Octon it's real but I could focus
on others and find other effects and uh
it's
it's it's it's overwhelming and as I
said I started this hoping to find you
know one or two effects instead of
drowning in effects and and spending the
remainder of my life is this Johnny
Appleseed character who's trying to go
around and plant the seeds of future
science in the minds of young graduate
students and some of my colleagues to to
pay attention to these so it's they're
way more questions than answers way way
more questions
than answers Gary you had one and I'll
open one so well do you answered I
enjoyed it
um you've talked about your work with
the trichoderma Verity and it uh we see
that very commonly as an ear mold on
corn and we've always put that in kind
of a benign category as compared to the
known mycotoxin producing molds yeah on
corn should we question that assumption
now
I I don't know
yeah I I don't know one answer I can't
really answer on that one
um some of these trichodermas do make
toxins and certainly in feeds we go back
to where I started that I didn't talk
about much there's no question that some
of the secondary metabolites fungi maker
are going to make animals sick there's
um Verity I don't know what kind of
metabolize it makes but a lot of
trichodermas make some bad stuff they're
they're better in BIO control than
growing on on your on your crane I yeah
thank you yeah before we go
gross uh is a concentration dependent
phenomenon yeah there's a lot of
concentration stuff here and many of
these things at low levels are doing
good and as they go up higher or toxic
and so and and then you put in more than
one as I say it is so complicated but
with my reductionist ways we like taking
one compound and trying it in a bunch of
different concentrations often we're
doing our experiments at concentrations
that are that are not not natural
because remember you have to enclose
stuff and that's not how things are in
the world and so it's always a problem
that we recognize that we have an
artificial world when we do our
experiments but you've got to start
somewhere
and uh that's that's where we're
starting but yes they're very
concentration dependent very
concentration dependence we have one in
the chat um that they ask consumed can
you please expand on what is known about
vocs in the penicillium species
associated with cheeses should we be
concerned if we start our calendar
of course
um I do not know much about the
volatiles of cheeses
um I do know that they are a case of
something that smells really terrible
and tastes really good and that's always
been a mystery to me it's kind of the
reverse of coffee which smells really
good and tastes really terrible
and uh I I wouldn't be particularly
worried
um I I think that we have a lot of
history of of eating these cheeses with
nothing but pleasure but a
um they have found toxins from some of
these penicillin species mycotoxins and
we go on eating them everything in
moderation as they used to say and uh
but yeah
and it's a good question
are there any more questions from Geneva
or zoom in general
um chat or just by speaking up
I don't think they are okay hey thank
you all for coming yeah
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu